è servita per i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fatti già oggi stiamo
con ciccio ciao come l'ultima volta ho
giocato a dragonball fighters però non
sapevo una sega di come la mischia
schiacciavano tasti a caso cio mi ha
dato le dritte su come partire e quindi
adesso facciamo una partita seria dove
le prenderò le mazzate alla famiglia
finale to save psych elite e indovina
chi sono io vuoi un indizio da me allora
l'indizio è che devi utilizzare le turca
di cervello perché se legino meter
accorgi subito chi sono i super sayan j
dai kiwi che si adagerà fine ma sei
album come fai a combattere contro i
nomi veri neanche come bull ma cazzo ma
ad ora che cazzo fare proprio pullman o
7 e cioè il simile ma che vuoi vai tu
perché non ho idea di come si gioca la
pace 1 con un megafono mi fa troppo
ridere
allora abbiamo si fa mi ha fatto vanto
sceglie personaggi ma io non ho neanche
scelti persona ma cos'è vai tu puoi
giocare to nord ma in realtà dove farlo
prima però non troppo spiegato quindi
scusa grazie ai meravigliosi e ciccio
era insieme è un modo per vincere ma
spetta a scusa scusa scusa non ha fatto
niente però ho capito a chi appartato
esatto
[Musica]
e vabbè vabbè totale a picchiare lorenzo
che vince o l'unica volta ho appena
bevuto un litro di yogurt e quindi sono
forte wow nero porta fammi notare un
attimo tutti perché scelto sti
personaggi avevo per un ok la tua
tattica cosa no no no sia stata attiva
però al troppo note ma devi tenere tu
non ti devi tenere presenti su carta
vetro dei spaccato da spacca bene il
quadro non spacca per te
e va bene non riesco a parare neanche
niente protesta aspetta siamo viking 1 e
n
che male di capannori prendi poi
continuare per una vita e mezzo si
diventa perché comunque è tutto
collegato da picchia picchia picchia
ciccio che dovrà fare di qui vieni qua
domanda esattamente quando uno dovrebbe
caricarsi appena la riguarda in effetti
caricare un po risotto di diciamo che
laura poi recuperarla tanto golf dando
pugni
laura la puoi recuperare con le coppie
che io morto porca eva marcata tra morto
freezer come venne fuori dai 40 e papà e
vabbè non esservi da niente rendere
questo la il soft saprei cosa fare cosa
mi pare un capo distretto meteorite pesa
è servito a qualcosa
perfetta si sta per culo o se goku ago
sei tu
va bene no ma com'è posti così tirato
due attacchi va bene va bene questa
volta l'ho sentita potente ma va
guarda la li che sa come ciccio non sa
neanche come ho fatto a fare sta cosa
peggiore non so ma trovo regalo salzano
con due vivi e lui con uno è impossibile
detto questo effetto si sta impegnando
sta vendola o card ecco ok perfetto non
ha detto ho parlato e sono rimasti uno
contro uno regalo perfetto trans contro
blake giochi bastardate morì a me mi
avrai capito madonna la spada buono
torna a meta mangiare il mio look ma
cosa fanno i vampiri quando la persona
il ciclo non voglio saperlo grazie per
avermelo detto avevo bisogno di sentirmi
dire
e da ci stavano possibile che devi
menarmi mag n ok questa destra da
giorgio carico fa sul serio a braga sul
serio
[Applauso]
l'ha fatto che vale attaccante
carreggiata e catechetica sono detti e
va bene non ho neanche che andava fatto
niente basketball odio e il peso di più
fastidioso oggi ho sbagliato ho
sbagliato ho cambiato non volevo se ci
dice 8 no no alto lanciato mi sa tanto
prendo doppio cosa ho fatto
devi fare tu fai dopo addio ma dopo
questo facendo pensare che quando
facendo offerte del momento di andare
sul serio
anche questa volta che certo non stiamo
capendo noi sa che la sta succedendo
no mai potuto stop ok per come va bene
64 palesi cuore morto niente 26 pronto
ciccio per questo incontro mi gioco buon
milione di iscritti
per questo incontro in giù il mio canale
ok quanti iscritti a 94.000 prova beh
sono sempre meglio di niente
vabbè dai por che robe come puntare un
centesimo vai che batte i dissidi adesso
ci amiamo in acqua
va bene ok tu hai preso in giro erano
cavalca la pagina si gira pontese amena
questa mera dei qua non so è che la sta
facendo un secondo per combattere
combatte provava si le donne per
combattere viene informata del sinn
adesso che regalava aiuto mai male
posare uno da genero che sono tuo padre
ok siamo più o meno messi simili
vabbè questa volta vedrai
ho cominciato a ciccio grande c18 vorrei
che ci dice perché ho fatto il cambio si
sia esatto nato un conflitto a meno una
volta no no perfetto manca tutto avevano
paura maschiata inizi accanto vai fuori
perché son diventato nero gaza cosa
esserci perché se diventato nero le cose
dette forti lembo la decca non è
possibile che giochi il più nero ne sarà
si sta però non ho capito se fatto a
lampada è che hanno conti da piccolo
fantastic basta parola basta lo dico
basta 12 2
esatto va bene donna contro melma che
incoraggi a sono l'alfa woman
appunto per questo ora come lo stringato
male che non è vero che ma molto male
l'ho presa proprio tutta in faccia
fortissima e niente file ci sono
[Musica]
o no ok
può fare male è mai riuscito
era da un'ora che prova a fare l'ultima
mossa e non riusciva a farla adesso per
migliaia di iscritti loro e adesso ai
1.094.000 iscritti va bè ragazzi
altro giro altra corsa mi gioco un altro
milioni di iscritti ci sei
ci sono è dedita a loro paure da freezer
non ho paura solo parando qualche pecca
fuori casta succedendo
cosa sta succedendo sono impotente cazzo
mette fuori
se non ti carica che tanto ti ammazzo
prima roberta aiuto
porco demonio ma la fai stramaledetta
mossa minarono balla balla non la fa non
la famiglia farà da questa storia ho
tirato fuori miracle blaze gettoni bravo
vuole anche grazie che mi hai lasciato
torino resto per carità di dio va bene
chiamami fa vj se andate in sincro
perfetto notifica feed
abbiamo lo stesso avanti da di iscritti
ora ringrazio ciccio male grazie a te
quindi spero che vi sia piaciuto cosi si
evince momento mi piace anche ai social
minuto descrizione sosta vestiti
iscrivetevi io porca di una vacca ho
preso lei o furti invece che telecom
anche bei ragazzi
[Musica]